all right welcome back to safety blitz
this is segment rodney that we call
third and short three quick open-ended
questions for you we just get right into
it which team should have made a move
which team should have been aggressive
at the trade deadline and wasn't where
are you leaning with this one
interesting question i'm gonna start
with the green bay packers and obvious
obviously um robert tunyan he got hurt
so i'm thinking evan ingram more of a
pass catching receiving type um tight
end you already have mercedes-lewis
there as you're blocking tight end he's
outstanding a guy that can still catch
um but evan ingram could have been a
no-brainer for i mean because he's
athletic he's fast and he's he's you
know he's got some talent so i like that
what do you think about that evan ingram
tell him that's interesting i like that
i i like that i've always been hard on
the fence of they've got to get him a
few more pass catchers just get him a
few more especially with how often now
we're seeing devante adams be hurt i
mean just give him something man i feel
like he's back there and he's still able
to go do it i mean it's amazing he's
able to go into arizona on thursday
night on a short week going cross
country and go do it with you know his
third fourth and fifth wide receiver
that's aaron rodgers man but i would
have liked to see them maybe be
aggressive go after a guy like odell
beckham jr maybe go after a guy like
michael gallup down there with dallas as
they now have a situation where wilson
cedric wilson's becoming a legitimate
number three for them maybe they'd be
willing to move those guys maybe for a
player or for picks who knows but just
to go after one weapon would have been
interesting maybe the titans why why
don't the titans go pick up a running
back give up some picks give up somebody
where you have a surplus of talent one
of their positions and go get a running
back because i don't believe in their
backfield right now
yeah i don't believe in their backfield
either i mean adrian peterson i'm you
know he's a future hall of famer but
he's 30 something years old he hadn't
played he hadn't been in training camp
so like i'm not like super believing in
him i look at the tennessee titans and
you look at the running back position i
kind of look at the the defensive back
position where they can get it at
another corner they got some young
corners and they you know those young
corners they've been hurt they played
well they played a little inconsistent
but if you can go get a guy like kyle
fuller who's definitely unhappy in
denver and put him in he this is a guy
that can play zone he can play man he
can play cover two and he's tough and he
doesn't mind tackling an open field i
like kyle fuller
what about the saints for a quarterback
just go get somebody's back up some
whoever it is whatever you like uh i
doubt it's trubisky but true recipes
honestly look decent um case keenum
maybe like who's somebody that the
saints could have maybe brought in their
quarterback position i the weird thing
is right now this i thought you i think
you just said it in book
yeah you just said it
who would you just say which one did you
like
keenum i said case keenum i said mitch
trubisky
mitchell trubisky mitchell trubisky i
mean he's athletic
he's been accurate he got away from the
bears and all of a sudden it's like as
soon as he left matt nagy they came back
in the preseason and he looked like an
all-star he looked like a top pick that
you were picking you know it's like
mitchell trubisky can play but a lot of
times when you're in a bad situation and
you have a bad coaching situation
you're not going to be able to show your
talent so i would say yeah i would i
would have gave up something to get
mitchell trubisky why not
i like it okay you like that one i was
just floating out there for temperature
i didn't know if i was going to get
spiked at the line of scrimmage or what
so here's our second one on third and
short because we had thrown in there the
possibility of a cam newton a
possibility of cam newton going there to
new orleans would you prefer trubisky
over cam newton or what's your
temperature on newton overall in new
orleans
well i just i think with cam you know he
still has to come in and learn the
offense i mean think about it he was
with the patriots
you know the second year and he was
still learning the offense and you know
when you're in sean payton's offense it
requires a tremendous amount of accuracy
that's the thing about drew brees even
when his arm was jello toward the last
two or three years of his career he
could still he was still very accurate
and winston he's not the most accurate
guy but he can sling the ball down the
field so yeah i mean when i look at cam
you know i have a lot of respect for cam
i was the one yelling and screaming hey
sign can sign cam it didn't work out um
but i i don't think this would be a good
fit because i just don't think cam's
accurate and he's gonna struggle picking
up the system
i'm right there with you to me sean
payton's the coach of the year like we i
know we've been throwing that around
there's some young coaches that are
deserving there's some teams that have
had some legitimate turnarounds that are
deserving and i hear that and i'm right
here in cincinnati zach taylor he's one
of them but
man i i don't know that anybody has done
more with less specifically at the
quarterback position than what i'm
seeing right now with sean payton and it
still feels like they're going to
continue to win games i want to be
taysom hill maybe it'll be ian book
maybe they'll go pick somebody up i
don't know but it still feels like
they're going to continue to win games
get to the afc playoffs
defense defense
it is about that defense you're exactly
right which bubble team which bubble
team rod so here are the bubble teams
right new england kansas city cleveland
denver and indy which bubble team is
most likely to get into the playoffs
right now in your mind's eye
i got two and i told you about one last
week i said the kansas city chiefs i
said i don't care what goes on
at the end of the year the kansas city
chiefs will be right there i also
believe that the new england patriots
that defense is starting to play well
matt jones is starting to get a better
understanding when you watch the
patriots you watch mac jones he's
starting to run and scramble so to me
that tells me that he's getting a lot
more comfortable in the pocket around
the pocket seeing the defense seeing the
rush and all the different defenses so i
would say the pats and the chiefs andy
reid is a veteran coach he's not going
to panic right now it's been seven eight
games or whatever it's been he's not
gonna panic but i tell you
you get you get melvin ingram in there
and the defense starts playing a little
bit better patrick mahomes eventually
he's gonna come around watch out for the
kansas city chiefs i know
you know it may not look like it right
now but i'm just a guy that believes in
kansas city and andy reid and patrick
mahomes
and then clyde edwards elaire gets
healthy now here's the problem for
kansas city right and i totally agree
with you on the patriots the patriots
they just warm up through september
through october nobody knows that better
than you they're just warming up out
there and then they start playing their
best football and i think we're starting
to see that come to life kansas city
though their upcoming schedule their
next seven opponents all above 500. you
look at their names on paper and they're
tough packers raiders cowboys bye week
then they go broncos raiders chargers
steelers bangles denver so they're only
two sort of easily winnable games on
paper or to denver they're four and four
but the rest of those games roddy what
comes to mind when you hear that
schedule coming up that sounds pretty
tough based on the struggles they've
already had
well cleveland doesn't i mean like
denver doesn't scare me indy doesn't
scare me i mean you still have to
respect those teams but it's not like
it's it's to the point where oh we know
we're going to lose to this team because
they're so good all those teams are
bubble teams they all have weaknesses
and you talk about the indianapolis
coach at three and five well
carson wentz is their quarterback so you
don't know how he's going to respond to
having a bad game there's a lot of
unknowns when it comes to the
indianapolis coats and carson wentz at
the quarterback spot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports